pascale what's the difference between
making $500 movie versus an $85,000
exactly the same seriously it's just it
just goes to different aspect of it but
it was not more complicated because when
I do a film I'm trying to manage that to
do it with a bare minimum and for
example that's him on the horizon we did
it I did it with 85 grand but mostly it
went for traveling actors food plane
ticket and stuff like that so it goes
fast like like this so when it's time to
do the budget it's not that complex so
when you do a 585 frame I'm using
exactly the same technique I used a shot
the same way it was not the only thing I
had it was a bigger camera but other
than that it was exactly the same
process which camera was it I used the
red dragon and I wanted why ever used
that because I was debating I was like
ah how do I go with the Canon whatever
and with the red because I know that it
was going to be chaotic so many location
outside traveling all the time and I
know some time I might miss something so
the fact that with the ROC footage you
can fix everything later so that was a
fail-safe a little bit with on the
horizon you had it as a short film first
and then you decided to make it as a
feature yeah did you notice aside from
you know the longer script did you
notice that there were things that
surprised you about lengthening the
movie no for me it was more first and I
can go in right away that I love doing
short films short film is about finding
your style finding a signature and so I
had an idea I wanted to do it and first
of all distortion on the horizon was I
shot that in like three hours and it
came out amazingly we shot in the desert
and everything so when I did that I was
in the process of finding my source my
funding for the feature film that I was
searching for like $300,000 it was like
it's a lot of money so I was like can I
make when that idea was just like can I
make that story of the under eyes and
and just three because I had a version
of the script and can I just reshape
everything to make it around 60 grand 85
and and I scale it down and I was asking
favours from people and you know it's
kind of a cliche but yeah you ask people
fevers sponsors and then it worked out
and it just something by doing something
it clicks an idea and when I did that
for him that was the revelation of oh
let's screw the 300 let's make it for
maybe 60 and I'm sure it's gonna be
easier to find investors and it worked
I often hear filmmakers say they want to
make something that they don't have the
budget and they do it so you know that
they're looking at you know million
dollar-plus
how was it for you to come to that
decision that if I'm going to do this
that it has to be this this is all I may
get for it and I still want to make it
yeah but I've been doing this for the
past 10 years 15 years and I've always
used the same technique I've no no crew
you know I do everything myself some
time and makeup and but mostly like on
the horizon was done with me my son guy
and assistant that's it and that that's
a lot of work to do a feature film three
people so I did everything I was driving
giving the food I was just I've never
slept but by doing so if you know you
can do so much job and you know you
let's say you know I don't need a DP
because I know I can shoot beautiful
images so by that you save money and
then so if you know you can end a lot of
work that's where you shrink your budget
down and I think it goes with passion
dedication
there's always gonna be excused not to
do anything so that's what for me I was
just like stop waiting for money stop
waiting for anything you can do if you
have the passion you're gonna create
anything you want you can shoot it got
nothing to shoot in the desert it costs
nothing to shoot near the ocean and you
have amazing visual so it's endless
where you can choose so I think it's
just excuse for people can be lazy
sometime are you comfortable in saying
where you got the funding from or it's
private it's private investment it's
private so I beacon does I think I'm
from Montreal but I don't you in
Montreal so I can not use government
money grant and yeah I cannot use grants
and stuff like that and then when I go
to the state's I can apply because I'm
left American so I don't have any choice
to go into the private funding so I was
lucky I've certain you know people where
did you
that money I just asked everyone and
it's I didn't want to do the Kickstarter
thing you need to have an army to do
those things and I didn't I didn't I
don't have the patient to do that what I
want to shoot something I want to shoot
it now and so I ask people and people
people people and there's the thing
where you have at least short films
music videos and you have amazing demo
reel you have a good material to show
the people and you have a business plan
that's what I did I did a business plan
I have my great demo reel beautiful
website to at least showcase everything
and then it's easier to contact people
so I had one person that loved my work
say how I got someone in Texas who can
maybe was interested so I talked to the
guy I showed in my work business plan
and he said yes so it's a lot of
people's always you know but it's kind
of true you know but not just that it
was being ready and you already had a
body of work exactly yeah it's gonna be
impossible if you never done short film
or you just barely start you don't have
a great demo reel and you think you're
gonna have like $350,000 there's no I
don't know good luck with that because
people work with visual you need to be
able to show you know just even for my
business plan it was mostly all pictures
so yes you have the numbers and
everything but that's for business
people that's important but at the same
time they want to see that you have your
clear vision because that's what they
are investing in you know a clear vision
that hope is gonna make some money but
uh so yeah the fact that you have your
style your signature that you have a
body of work then that's gonna be more
impressive and then you way they google
you and you have magazine and interviews
whatever that see they see that you've
travel a little bit it's way more
reassuring that you fail and then I just
came out of school and I hope to get
$300 $300,000 because I were I wrote a
script
who cares there's like million people
who do that so at least a visual to
apply to do that business plan
you